it's
time nearly 30 years after Mariah Carey
released All I Want For Christmas Is You
the five-time Grammy Award winner is
still reaping the benefits of the
instant Christmas
classic billboard reported last year
Carrie grossed $1.55 million in annual
recording royalties from each time the
song's Master recording is played or
sold plus as much as $830,000 in
publishing royalties before fee for the
use of the
music Carrie pulls in an estimated
millions of dollars in royalties each
year off the holiday Anthem and launches
an annual holiday tour around the song
called Merry Christmas one and all the
tour runs between November 15th and
December 17th this year All I Want For
Christmas Is You is the highest charting
holiday single by a solo artist on the
billboard us Hot 100 according to
Guinness World Records the song which
was released in 1994 also became the
first holiday sing single certified
diamond by the recording industry
Association of America in
2021 Carrie Sony music and All I Want
For Christmas Is You co-writer Walter
aasf were named in a $2 million
copyright infringement lawsuit last year
by songwriter Andy Stone who claimed
defendants made a derivative version of
Stone's 1989 song by the same name which
was released under the artist's name
Vince Vance and the valian stones
attorneys voluntarily dismissed the suit
last November but filed another lawsuit
in November of 2023 car's legal team has
not commented on the recent lawsuit All
I Want For Christmas Is You has been
covered by dozens of artists including
Michael Bublé Dolly Parton ingred
Michaelson Shania Twain Ariana Grande
Demi Lovato and Lady a Kerrie also
re-released the song in 2011 with Justin
Bieber as of 2017 the song had generated
over $60 million through royalties since
its release according to an estimate by
The
Economist